hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma we're
going into the forest now now this is an
area that I've never seen boo I gotta
say the ambience in this game he's
wonderful hello anybody in these hidey
holes over here anybody uh oh I'm not
touching that flower Alice I got the
glove no just no okay I'm gonna keep the
glove on just in case I got any goobers
you want to be touched just stick it in
no okay all right well he seems awfully
unassuming but I don't want to assume
anything about its unassuming nature all
right seems to be pretty clear right oh
I probably shouldn't touch that bear
trap down I'm assuming that's the noise
of confirmation the yes mark that would
be stupid to put your hand in a bear
trap and I'm not gonna do that
hello dink donk no not that way pink
pink let's throw a rock at your window
can I put my hand down wise man down sir
so long carrying on Poochie are you
doing are you a rat what's with your
tail hello can I pet you would you like
a nice tasty bear head how's your okay
thought you were gonna be upset or maybe
it's just that I can't go any farther
with your Standing Bear hey a bird's
nest
that's not disturb it birds like me
right now ok i got a key dink donk
witch's house which old witch should we
talkin about here
nice meat okay Klunk Klunk
kloor flu let's go nice brooms nice
chest
nice jars nice bookshelf nice well I did
that so what's the point of that though
I don't want the meat I'm gonna have
bloody hands okay well I got meat maybe
I can feed the meat to the DAO gee maybe
I could put the meat in without be bad
maybe I could just give it to the dog
the dog rat crunch okay well that's good
better than putting it in the bear trap
and getting that old dead oh hi sir hi
let's go and you camping are you lost I
lost I can give you a lift to town but
first I need to chill and relax it's
just a pity that I did not take any bait
with me it's so boring here be great if
you found a worm for me all right okay
all right okay all right sure
I've got a plethora of worms Hey
what are you doing I just wanna see the
inside of your tent man what are you
trying to hide don't go there I'll give
you something over here ooh yeah oh is
that okay I got a worm hey these puzzles
are easy to solve everything is always
immediately adjacent here's a worm can
you find me some bait get a worm right
gonna work oh do you need more than one
worm is that what we're talking about
here also what's with the bloody tree
that's a body that's a body oh hi I
don't want your worm if you've got a
worm I don't want it okay well there's a
cheerful place there's a leg
did he get a gumdrop it's good thing
that guy's chilling and relaxing in a
place oh so chill and relaxed such as
this all right I'll find you some more
worms I guess ooh can I poke that with a
stick no okay
all right then carrying Oh a car hello
oh this is that guy's car okay so I need
to find somewhere rooms wherever I can
find some worms all right there wouldn't
be any in here maybe I can find some
more worms uh-huh
oh no why are you so lazy I gotta put it
on your own fishing pole for you what
kind of weirdo are you thanks man
now I need to get some rest okay okay
all right
give you a lift after I take some rest
okay you you do that I don't know what
the point of that was but okay I just
I'll go rest in the witch's house which
old witch oh the witch house over there
can I get some Honi can I get some bear
I'm gonna let you on fire
gonna do any event oh hi hello I didn't
even notice you there this is a energy
drink recipe spiny flower nasty mushroom
rotten fish dirty worm letes berries
grain okay all right then okay I'm gonna
get a spiny flower with this glue ha ha
got it with a glove all right nasty
mushroom now which one of these is nasty
how do you know which one's a nasty one
I mean that's a little that's a little
presumptuous
so I guess I gotta make I gotta make
some sort of a who shouldn't
I gotta make a Bhushan to boost him out
of the way whatever he's doing or maybe
I can give an energy drink to the guy so
that it feels all rested just gotta find
me a nasty shroom now you all look
pretty honey can I get some honey lower
hello look at some Khun lo nest grain
hey I got grain are you getting rest
thanks for the help can I take that fish
I got some fish okay I don't know why
I'm going with the fish but I got it
alright oh maybe I can get a oh I got
bad I don't know if that was okay you
have a nasty worm can I take your nasty
worm can you donate some nasty worm
alright whatever I'm gonna good oh that
was a nasty mushroom alright I assume
the nasty mushroom would be on the groom
let's see about tossing some of these in
[Music]
cuz I walked in this world probably well
I think there's only like a one or two
more ingredients so we got the spiny
flower nasty mush and rotten fish dirty
worm leach berries we need berries we
need berries wait are we missing one I
think we need a dirty woman we need
berries dirty Worman berries so where
are we gonna find a dirty worm where
we're gonna find berries there's gonna
be in a bush
I know berries are on bushes that's
something I do know so I just gotta find
a berry bush so I can get what I need
you're very much to be very very Bush
very Bush breath
what are you can I have you can I put
you in a jar
I got berries I got berries in a jar for
some reason that's what I needed to do
with that now I need to find a nasty
worm a real stinker of the worm a real
son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
berries are in so I need a nasty one
oh hey I got a worm from the fish pile
that makes sense I guess flop in you go
hey cool jar no come on no well there's
got to be everything
what else am I missing got the spiny
flower we got the mushroom fish worm
leach berries grain no it's definitely
all in there sir your recipe is [ __ ]
Oh
Oh I needed an empty can
oh I get it an energy drink needs to be
in a can okay let's fill that bad boy up
with red balls and give it o to our good
friend here hey you want some energy
drink you want to get some wings
thanks you should give me a kick all
right if it doesn't kill them because I
don't know I put a lot of weird [ __ ] in
that much better even though I
mysteriously look like that cannon that
garbage pile by me
now we can get going let's go to my car
oh I see how it is I gotta do all your
chores for you sir we need to find
something sticky and for god I don't
like where this is going
why don't you find your own sticky
substance and I go off in the other
direction all right finally gotta find a
sticky substance I gotta find something
sticky that no can I poke that with a
stick
honey's pretty sticky yeah yes hello oh
I get a fishing rod I bet I got a fish
you over in here yeah oh that's whoa you
got a light cuz I do you wanna you
wanted me to light this for you buddy
okay all right thanks for that thank you
for that don't know why I got that
happen all right hey buddy you wanna you
want a cigarette one thanks but got my
own smokes dot dot dot okay then why did
I need to fish this one out of the dead
I could ask you for one if I really need
it
I find it oh oh is it oh did the witch
come back home and not like me messing
around with the witches school what
someone seems to be good hello what was
that why did you do that okay I'm gonna
assume that I'm fine still haven't
figured out what I need to do but I'm
assuming a fun can I stay I can't stick
this bare head in the window and scare
the witch wait doesn't smoke aah
smoke smoke bees don't like smoke or
they do they like either way they become
complacent with smoke oh now I can do
ah that's goo I got goo why Sharjah bees
bees producing goo I didn't want to
steal the bees goo does he exactly not
what I wanted to steal am I still okay
alright I'm still fine apparently there
have some goo hey I made this fresh
batch of goo you better appreciate it
it's straight from the tap if you know
what I mean
disgusting and stinky thank you I pride
myself on my sticky goo it's useless
whoa [ __ ] van oh [ __ ] you
you took my jar in my stinky goon you're
just gonna turn your nose and go poopoo
to my goo well [ __ ] you I'm fine without
the useless turn of events why did I
even do that I fished fished a cigarette
out of there for nothing hassle well yet
now I'm back at square dickory
[Music]
oh I didn't go in here oh this would
have been smart to look in his stuff oh
good used gum oh good here you want some
of your own used gum sir it should work
why would that work not the boom give me
a moment are you gonna use my good with
that
honestly you better use my goo for cuted
sake you turning up your nose my dude
all right well that's awfully nice can
we go now done we're good to go
all right good I feel like there was a
lot in that level that I didn't pieced
together weird well anyway we're done
with so anyway that is the end of this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching we're gonna be getting to the
bottom of this mystery very soon so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]